so it happened it actually happened
sooner and I thought - now for someone
like me trying to go from absolutely
unknown to hopefully more known moments
like these are to be remembered someone
infringed me yeah infringed so I was
checking my hits on my New Moon review
when I noticed on the related videos
column I apparently had some other New
Moon review that I never did I saw that
this video had my face on it it was
titled new to moon Jeremy Jones or some
[ __ ] I knew I clearly did not make this
video so I just had to click on it check
it out maybe it was gonna be cool who
knows so I click on it and what did I
find it was some [ __ ] fake credit
card ad you know one of those come to
our website at we suck ass calm so you
can apply for a fake credit card and
want to kill yourself after we steal
your social security number yeah pretty
much the gist of it they had ripped my
video from YouTube slapped their little
credit card ad at the beginning which
was just a blue page with some orbs on
it and re-uploaded it under their name
and now to be clear I don't particularly
care if someone uses my image or face
people have asked me if they can feature
my videos and their videos and stuff and
I'm like yeah or whatever but if someone
tries to use my video for the sake of
their internet ripoff scams screw that I
mean as it was the video was up for like
six hours and it felt like I was already
sponsoring the under dealings of some
Nigerian internet cafe and I tried to
see the whole optimistic side of it I
tried to see the whole no publicity is
bad publicity thing but fact is it
wasn't publicity it was some [ __ ]
trying to scam people like you by using
my videos and upon my want to look on
the brighter side of this situation the
fact remained I just didn't want to be
that guy you know that guy who naively
tried to convince everybody that the
shittiest situations are actually
awesome when there's just no positive
way to spin it like this guy well I mean
yeah I was tea-bagged but I mean you
know there were a lot of people there
and of everyone who slept like this I
was the only one whose mouth that one of
their balls in so I mean you know
technically he's bacon you know that
makes me close on there yeah right yeah
I'm not gonna be that guy because the
fact is I was digitally diddled by a
stranger who did not have a bike for me
like you promised bastard so it had to
be
adopt so now the videos gone I still
want to know what dumbass decided to use
my videos you know I mean you think the
conversation went something like how do
we reach the most amount of people
possible whose video should we use Phil
DeFranco no new new that cute Asian girl
with the Aussie accent no no no ha I've
got its Jeremy Jones yes we should I use
his videos 800 or so subscribers ha
might as well be eight million
dramatization may not have happened and
apparently my Nigerian scam artists
sound like they're from Scotland Yard
there is nothing out there saying that
members of Scotland Yard don't operate
out of shady Nigerian internet cafes it
could happen
so look out internet apparently some
[ __ ] with a British accent running
scams out of his mom's basement in
Nigeria probably operating under the
guise of a female with the username rope
[ __ ] on bondage calm thinks my videos
are worthy to use to rip people off oh I
just feel like a force to be reckoned
with right now I feel like I need to
make it impossible for someone to use my
videos to run their scams anymore you
know like at the beginning of every
video I'll just scream if there's a
website at the beginning of this video
the person who put it there has a baby
dick yeah have fun using that video to
run your scams mr. douche fake credit
card company ripoff douche bag yeah I'm
not going to use it now are you defused
things we have to do to protect
ourselves in this day and age oh yeah
screaming insults into the camera more
secure than life lock and more mature
kinda oh and don't forget to click on my
link on the sidebar and subscribe to
this channel so you can see more
fact-based videos exposing life for what
it really is ridiculous